what's up marissa so i'm calling today
with a concern that
i feel like a lot of americans have
right now
about just the anxiety over the mass
shootings
recently and just the fear of going out
in public going to the grocery store and
um
it's just it has me really anxious and
when i'm in the grocery store i'm in and
out as fast as possible and i'm looking
around
at everybody like they're a threat and
it's just not a sustainable way to live
and i just
wondered how you thought we should go
about handling that anxiety
hey thank you so much for that call
marissa i'm grateful that you called
because you're exactly right
everyone i know is wrestling with it and
struggling with it and thinking through
it
and um it's an unsettling
feeling it's unsettling time right let's
just be honest with it
um so the best way i can answer that is
to tell you directly how i handle it
is that okay um i don't have any major
scientific studies or anything like that
i can just tell you what i'm doing
personally
um and i'll also tell you i've responded
to
actual scenes of gunshot victims i've
been in there i've helped clean those
scenes up i've helped move them those
body it's
i've been there and so i i know what
the with that i just
i have an intimate knowledge that i know
what it's like and so
when i see some of these things they
will set off my alarms all our brains
are trying to do is take care of us
right
and the more we feed at this stuff over
and
over and over the more
our brains start looking for it because
it wants to keep us safe
and what we've entered into with our
media world and i don't want to blame
media because these things are really
happening
right but they're not happening at every
grocery store they're not happening at
most
grocery stores they're not happening at
the vast majority of grocery stores or
schools or colleges or fill in the blank
but we have a media system that is paid
simply on how many eyeballs it gets how
many clicks it has
and so it has a vested interest in
pumping that information into our brains
any shape form or fashion and on top of
that
every person's got a camera now and
some of the justice oriented things
those cameras have been lifesavers
literally right
it's helped us see justice it's helped
us see another side of a story that we
never would have received
in other times it just gives us 84 new
angles of the same trauma and so these
um
media outlets are just recycling and
replaying all these different
clips our brains are registering these
clips all of them different
and it is just saying don't go to school
don't go to school don't go to school
school's not safe school is not safe
and all media is trying to do is just
get us to keep watching we can't we
can't turn our heads away from it right
and so yeah first and foremost i just
cut the media off
i cut it out i have very few people that
i
plug into anymore and they're folks that
i i value based on trust
and i can hear about it i don't need to
watch it i'm pretty selective about what
i choose to see
because i know my brain is going to do
its job and when it sees
something it's going to set off a system
of alarms and
chemicals and mechanisms to keep me safe
and sometimes it overrides my thinking
part of my brain
right and so if i hear about the latest
school shooting
in state x y or z
almost never am i going to plug in there
and go watch what just happened
almost never because i don't want that
in my head um
it was a few years ago i checked the
data recently but i did a
presentation for a group of college
professors after one or two
high-profile shootings at colleges and
interestingly at the time the data said
the safest job in the united states of
america the job you're most
the least likely to get killed at while
doing it was a kindergarten teacher
the next safest job was a college
professor
college instructor yet if you were to
have watched the news
my colleagues were like man we're next
right and we're gonna we're getting
often record numbers the data said
actually you're safe
it was the sensational coverage of this
of media over and over and
over now if we've seen a spike in
shootings no question about it
right but is it going on every single
place everywhere
it's not it's just not and so what
you've got to deal with is the reality
that it could happen
and the reality that it's probably not
going to happen
and the best way i have found is to stop
indulging the click fast stop
indulging all the drama to be vigilant
to be smart now i also found myself
i've been trained for some of these
situations and i've been trained to
get out of some of these situations is
that going to keep me safe probably not
right but you know you
know to look for it but i don't even
think that's necessary i think being
aware and build vigilant and then
recognizing the data is on your side
so i want to ask you give me an example
like you go to a store
and you mentioned you're out just
scoping people around what are you
looking for what do you think you're
going to see
uh i mean i'm just looking at people
looking at
looking to see if they look
i don't know like they're holding
something
or like they're just looking suspicious
i don't know really what i'm looking for
i'm just in and out as quick as i can or
i do click lists
um yeah but i am definitely guilty of
reading everything i can about every
shooting that happens
i just let my brain get lost in that
information
so here is a really fascinating thing
our brain does
when let's imagine back in the old days
and you you may have heard me say this
on the show a bear shows up at the front
of your cave
right you and your family are snuggling
they're nice and warm in a big pile
and a bear shows up you're you see that
bear
and your brain does not want you
thinking i wonder if that's a nice beer
is that our friendly
bear that comes around is that oh that's
the s the funny bear
it just has one rule run right or if you
can't run
fight grab sticks and uh rocks and if
you can't fight or run away
we're gonna shut the system down and
you're gonna freeze you're gonna play
dead and maybe he won't mess with you or
maybe he'll just drag you somewhere else
and give you a chance to escape
somewhere else right
when your brain goes into fight or
flight it
unhinges it unclicks your rational
thinking brain
it unhooks it and it trades accuracy for
speed
what does that mean just what you
described it's how
a police officer who gets a call on the
radio somebody running down alley
armed and dangerous fired off shots
um and their heart starts racing they
get out of the car and they are worried
about their own safety
and then somebody with a cell phone
right because your brain says
close enough let's make sure you're okay
or you're in a grocery store and you see
somebody walk by and it looks
kind of sort of similar to somebody on
the news and they're holding a
box of macaroni that kind of looks like
a whatever
boom you clinch your purse tighter and
you run out of that room
right so here's a way to combat that
number one
you're right turn off the news fight
that impulse
to just absorb all this info and by the
way
a lot of my friends absorb that info all
day and then they turn on some
murder podcast and or they watch and i'm
looking at you kelly
they turn on some murder podcast and
then they go home and watch law and
order svu for the 21st season or
whatever it is right
that's just all they consume 24 7. and
what you look for your brain will find
yeah right and so when that's all you
consume everyone is a creep everyone's a
criminal everyone's about to murder
everybody
here's the other thing you can do
besides turn off that nonsense
you can intentionally spend time
talking looking with people being with
them at a grocery store
saying hi how's your day going to people
standing in line with you
and listen when you first try this your
heart will beat because you'll be
nervous
and then hopefully the front part of
your brain will stop and go
is it so ridiculous that i'm nervous in
line at a grocery store
right and you'll realize oh that's just
a tired dad trying to buy some
chicken for right or that's a tired mom
who's you'll realize that
99.9999 of people
are lovely and kind and just trying to
get to the day too
so it's a decision to i'm going to slow
my breathing down
so my brain works i'm going to look
somebody behind say
a long line huh or how's it going or i
love your shirt
or are you having a good day right just
slow
entry-level communication and by the way
you throw a year away at a pandemic
right
and that's made it all worse now
everybody can get us sick and
kill us and all those things on top of
it right so
um not only are they going to shoot us
they can just breathe on us and it's all
over right so we are
at apex fear level
heightened heightened heightened and
people are getting shot
they are getting shot right we've had a
number of shootings right in a row in a
row in a row
um and unfortunately we're going to keep
having i mean
it's it's just escalating
um but you the reality is the data says
most of the time most of us are safe not
only are we safe
but we're surrounded by people who are
good folks who love us
and everyone's just kind of waiting on
everybody else to go first
and so it has become a a spiritual
practice of mine a mental health
practice of mine
to look people in the eye to smile extra
big
make sure people can see my hands at all
times this is stuff my dad taught me as
a little kid
to make sure i'm kind and make sure i'm
asking people how your day is
i would say seven or eight times out of
ten when you're going through a line
and the woman at the counter the man at
the counter is just
is going beep beep you know like uh
ringing your food up
and you just say hey how's your day
going they will
pause they'll freeze for a second
because they'll snap them out of their
mindless dull job and they'll look you
know and say
i'm done all right or not super great
right and you can share a laugh
a quick moment of humanity there but
marissa at the end of the day
the data tells us that most of us are
safe most of the time and it's our
choice to go looking for beauty
right and if you are in a situation if
you are in an environment that is
more dangerous if there's been more
shootings in your area
then i'm gonna advise you to go take a
class i'm gonna advise you to
um go be wise go meet with your local
authorities and say hey we're worried
about this area what are some things we
can do as a community
but chances are we're making ours not
chances are for sure
we are stressing ourselves out we're
much more likely to die of a stroke or a
heart attack or some sort of
inflammatory disease because we're
living in this heightened rattled stage
than we are being shot
okay or driving too fast or tripping on
the way out of the grocery store because
we're trying to get in and out so fast
slow down breathe deeply look people in
the eye
regain our humanity one hello hey once
you go ahead of me
go ahead and go first let me pick up uh
if you got the money i'm gonna pay for
her groceries
one at a time at a time thank you so
much for that call marissa you're
awesome i appreciate your heart there